nous avons rencontré donc l'organisateur
il ya des échanges sont déroulés d'abord
avec la mission carnaval mais également
suite avec les services de sécurité de
la préfecture la police nationale les
sapeurs pompiers en fait tous les
partenaires de manière à examiner
effectivement les conditions déroulement
de ses parents l'avantagé c'est que
cette parade que nous connaissons
puisque elle en est à sa 17e édition et
ce n'est pas traditionnel à fort de
france et nous faisons tout pour que non
seulement on n'a que les carnavaliers
dans de bonnes conditions mais que le
public aussi profitent au maximum de
cette opération
ce qui est particulier c'est que c'est
une parade nocturne et par conséquent il
faut veiller à ce que sur le plan de la
désinstallation
il n'y a pas de trou effectivement dans
les chaussées et que l'éclairage public
sont deux choses bien et c'est que tout
soit mis en place pour accueillir la
première de bonnes conditions et en fait
non rassemblements comme celui ci bon la
bête a fait devrait rassembler entre
quinze et vingt mille ps en général
peut-être un peu plus comme il ya
d'autres manifestations à allaman ce
n'est qu'à ce moment là
mais voilà on estime la fréquentation à
ce niveau là ce qui est déjà
considérable
c'est une manifestation comme ça c'est
évidemment des problèmes de circulation
de stationnement
c'est des problèmes aussi de sécurité
des personnes et des biens
puisque nous sommes en en centre-ville
vous avez des magasins vous avez aussi
des riverains
donc pourquoi non content aussi toute
une série de préoccupations et c'est
évidemment des questions d'utilisation
du domaine public par les commerçants
non sédentaires et c'est donc c'est tout
cela qu'il faut organiser mais nous
n'oublions pas l'objectif premier qui
est de faire en sorte que la fête soit
belle c'est surtout ça l'objectif c'est
de faire en sorte que la fête soit belle
mais notre mission c'est de créer le
cadre pour permettre aux gens de venir
tranquillement se gaver utiliser les
espaces de stationnement mis à leur
disposition fait en sorte que le pm est
réservé à la manifestation
on y trouve pas d'objets interdits dans
ma feu d'armes à destination d'armes
blanches et que le public puisse
profiter de la fête et surtout quand le
travail qui a été fait par les boues et
l'organisateur mai soit valoriser au
mieux